[Music]
the Big Brother contestants moved in
today but Kelsey Knight got the first
look inside yes healthy welcome I'm 99
daebak sorry surprise that's the twist
sixteen houseguests ninety-four cameras
ninety nine days season twenty is one of
the longest ever and the house is full
of surprises to keep guests entertained
while they compete for the
half-a-million dollar prize yeah where
are we going
if you want to climb the rock wall well
if there's a couch in your way yes and
for the first time ever it's one this
platform spins another twist this season
sigrid strategy meetings will be harder
to hide from the head of household in
the HOH bedroom the HOH is going to be
able to spy on rooms with a camera but
no audio that they never could spy on
before the head of household gets their
own better in the bathroom but the other
guests are two to a bed and there's even
less privacy this looks like a mirror is
it a mirror it's actually a mirror image
of this bedroom because we used to
separate the two bedrooms with the door
now it's just you can hear everything
good night Julie good night Kelty I
check out this room with 450 fidgets
spinners I mean this is perfect for when
they're bored
this season they added two more sinks to
the emoji theme two bathroom
all the new a funky kaleidoscope themed
lounge with a giant pin wall fall back
into it yes and let's see your imprint
on the other side that's a perfect booty
[Music]